Germany's Chancellor Angela Merkel is
rejecting president Trump's use of
outdated German crime numbers to justify
his controversial zero-tolerance
immigration policy in the United States
the president claimed on Twitter
yesterday that crime in Germany was up
more than 10% since migrants were
accepted there the latest figures show
that crime that the crime rate actually
fell last year the German government
says it's at a 25 year low in 2017
actually the president's false claims
are part of a growing list of issues
between mr. Trump and some of America's
closest allies Ian Bremmer president of
the Eurasia group is a CBS News senior
global global affairs contributor he
joins us from Tokyo in good morning so
the president has said the president has
said things are not as bad with Angela
Merkel as everybody's been saying why is
this important that they have a good
relationship and what do you think the
real nature for the relationship is the
relationship is about as dysfunctional
as we've seen between America and its
major allies since the transatlantic
relationship really started after World
War two I've spoken with most of the
delegations now that attended the g7
summit and they've all responded that
the relationship was very far from the
ten described by President Trump they
think it's deeply broken they feel that
their personal relationship with Trump
is deeply problematic and also that it's
increasingly hard to find independent
voices around him that they can engage
with that will get a message through
because they don't want to deliver
messages that Trump's advisers don't
want to deliver messages the Trump
personally doesn't want to hear there is
that picture that has now become famous
at the g7 summit the Atlantic wrote that
it's become kind of a laurel and yanny
moment with people having two different
views of it what have you learned about
what actually happened in that moment I
think the background is important it was
at this point it was towards the end of
the summit the Chancellor Merkel of
Germany and Prime Minister Trudeau of
Canada got together with some of the
allies and really wanted to press Trump
directly to sign the communique the one
that talked about a commitment to a
rules-based international order the
advisors had been working on until three
o'clock that morning straight through
the night including Kudlow
from the United States and Trump was
sitting there with his arms crossed
clearly not liking the fact that he felt
like they were ganging up on him he
eventually agreed he said okay he'll
sign it and at that point he stood up he
put his hand in his pocket his suit
jacket pocket and he took two starbursts
candies out threw them on the table and
said to Merkel here Angola don't say I
never give you anything and I would say
that that was a that really showed if
you won't if you want to look into what
was behind both the the body language
there and also why it was that after the
meeting Trump was so agitated and
decided to tweet off against the
Canadian Prime Minister and decide to
pull his name out of the communique a
completely unknown to Kudlow and others
that had been advising him I think
that's that's really the reason that's
his emotional state of that book so
President Trump had a starburst outburst
look I mean his personal relationship
with Merkel is deeply broken the leaders
obviously do not respect each other they
don't think that the other respects them
and it's pretty clear that they don't
and Trump's interest in multilateral
institutions that for him it feels like
a constraint not an opportunity but
looking at it from his point of view
could he possibly have been teasing and
meant for that to be a friendly gesture
is there any way that you could read
that in is there any way you could read
that into it you know it's hard to
keeping in mind that Trump didn't want
to go to the g7 he was convinced by his
advisors the day before that he needed
to and one thing we know about Trump is
when he's told to do things that he
doesn't want to do he doesn't respond to
them easily he showed up late he left
early he took his translation piece out
of his ear when the French president was
actually giving a speech he showed an
extraordinary lack of interest in
working with the allies all the way
through and again the private
conversations I've had with many of
these leaders over the course of the g7
summit really does express that concern
that level of concern I've been here in
Tokyo I've talked with many that
attended that meeting and they were
they've been extraordinarily
disheartened with the nature of the
relationship directly between Ave and
Trump all right Ian Bremmer when you're
back here in the States will get a more
debrief on what you learned over in Asia
thank you so much he and we appreciate
it